and welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of little damage
your weapons will do I will take your
weapons and deliver lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy Eric you're first you
ready for this yes sir right let's do
this
[Music]
all right Eric let's talk about your
Waldo here it is forward heavy there's a
lot of metal in here but it is wieldable
now your Edge is sharp it penetrates
deeply into this Village's dummy cutting
the gel torso and into the bones overall
sir you're a Waldo
it will kill thank you all right Dave
your turn sir you ready yes sir let's do
this
foreign
about your Waldo here it is a little bit
heavier than the other weapon heavier
weapons require a lot of adjustments but
your edge here is sharp with this
forward weight that cuts deep into this
malicious dummy and cuts the bones
inside but in doing so sir your Edge
over here did take a little bit of
rolling but the other parts
are fine
and overall sure you're a Waldo
it will Keel thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
we're calling this one the bamboo Man
attack
to test the overall construction of your
blade I'm going to take them and gently
tap them again start bamboo man over
here
now remember this is not about what your
weapons do to these targets it's about
what these targets do your weapons Eric
you're up first you ready yes sir all
right
laughs
[Music]
so Eric right off this is a heavy Beast
your balance Point's not bad I kind of
like that right there where you can
manipulate the weapon as far as the
weapon performance goes you maintain an
edge all the way along it's still sharp
nice and done thank you
all right Dave you're up ready yes sir
[Music]
all right Dave
your weapon is really really heavy so
you can make a devastating cut but
recovery is is really slow as far as the
blade
the blade itself is is dented sideways
here
and up above here
but
still solid so you survived quite nicely
well done Dave thank you
blade Smiths this is the sharpness test
the sugar cane slice
to find out how sharp your weapons are
I'm gonna attempt to cut through all
these sugar canes unlike the strength
test this is all about what your weapons
do and how well they cut the Sugar Kings
are you ready to do this yes sir
[Music]
all right Eric let's talk about your
edge here your Edge it's sharp it cuts
through all the sugar canes and overall
sir your weapon it will cut thank you
David your attorneys are you ready for
this yes sir
all right Dave let's talk about your
weapon here
it's still sharp and it cuts cleanly all
the way through but the weight of your
blade as I'm cutting drag downward and I
ran out of sugarcane but overall sir
your weapon it will cut thank you
well gentlemen you both performed
extremely well in our Korean theme
challenge both are Waldo's did great
during our tests but this is a
competition and there has to be a winner
the judges have made the decision
in today's Fortune fire Champion is
Eric congratulations
Now Dave you fought hard but
unfortunately you're not today's winner
and Dave's going to tell you why
Dave your blade did great in the kill
test and did well in the sharpness test
what this came down to are two things
the overall weight of your blade and the
Damage it took in the strength test
those are the reasons we're letting you
go I understand thanks for having me
well Dave it's clear you have what it
takes to find this Forge in extremely
talented Smith but unfortunately your
time in this competition has ended and
for that reason I'm gonna have to ask
you to please step off the forge floor
well Eric you know what that means you
are the newest Fortune fire Champion
you're going to be walking out of here
with a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
I feel awesome coming out here winning
the competition having my skills
validated this is a crowding achievement
of mine well done thank you
if somebody wants me to make a Waldo
it's going to cost him 10 grand